[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar I'm very excited about this video
because today we're going to be talking
about the coolest and most popular
character in attack on Titan captain
Levi we are going to get to the root of
this clean freaks insane superhuman
powers I just want to give a quick
warning that there will be some Unga
spoilers in this video because there
would be absolutely no way to do this
question justice otherwise I want to
thank everyone for the awesome response
that we've gotten on the every Titan
explained and who is the strongest Titan
videos it's insane and if you're new to
this channel be sure to subscribe for
more attack on Titan and anime related
content he is often referred to as and
understood to be humanity strongest
soldier search up Levi's name on YouTube
and you will see compilations that show
some of his epic moments people
regularly call him godlike or talk about
him entering into god mode he took down
the strongest Titan who only escaped
with his life because a fellow Titan
shifter rescued him in the nick of time
Levi's insane abilities begged the
question what is his secret well in the
newest manga chapter the secret has
finally been revealed zeke explains and
there is the line once thought to exist
only in legends told by the royal family
the Ackermann claim byproducts of titan
science at least two members seem to be
there honestly i never want to meet him
again this is crazy
we literally have the current strongest
titan scared shitless of the Ackerman's
which includes Levi and Mikasa we always
thought that they were extremely strong
humans but no it turns out that both
Levi and Mikasa are the products of
titans science all of a sudden
everything makes sense their godlike
power endurance and instincts are the
result of Titan science this seems to
have been foreshadowed as far back as
I've sold 5 into manga we jump into a
random scene with Micah's and her
parents before they get killed Mikasa is
complaining that her bandaged arm hurts
while her mother tells her that this
brand must be passed down from
generation to generation in our family
which I'm guessing means the mother's
new Ackerman family this brand might
well be related to the Ackerman's being
bribe products of tightened science
there were other clues too like the fact
that Mekas have scored top of her class
when everyone else in the top 5 Rainer
burr told Annie and Aaron were Titans
it is also believed that Amir who ranked
11 could have usually ranked within the
top 10 but she wanted historia to get
10th place so purposely held back more
on the Ackerman's before facing Kenny
Ackerman who is the oldest brother of
Levi's mother and Todd Levi everything
he knows Levi questions me cus up about
the Ackerman's but she only knows that
her father's family was persecuted and
not the reason why
Levi then asks her whether she
experienced a moment when she felt a
sudden power awaken inside her which
must relate to this Titan power upon
confirming this Levi tells mica said
that he and Kenny also experienced such
moments in their lives during this
awakening Ackerman seemed to feel
immense strength surged through their
bodies and know exactly what to do later
on in episode 65 of the manga Kenny's
grandpa tells him that the royal family
doesn't hate the Ackerman family they
fear them one of the reasons is that
because the Ackerman's are a minority
bloodline their memories can't be erased
or rewritten and therefore they cannot
be controlled they supposedly oppose the
first King because he wanted to wipe out
humanity given their immense Titan
related power and their inability to be
controlled it makes sense that even the
powerful royal family was scared of them
so now the question is what is this
insane Titan science that creates humans
that in many cases as Levi has shown
with the beast Titan can surpass a
Titans power in human form if they were
created using Titans then do they also
suffer from Amir's curse or do they live
full superhuman lives
are these powers somehow related to
ninth Titan did the royal family somehow
infuse the power of the ninth and still
unknown Titan power into the acraman
bloodline when they were still a warrior
family that protected them one thing is
for sure though this revelation
definitely raises as many questions as
it does answers but I can't wait to get
more information about the Ackerman's
the brand on Mika says risk and what
byproducts are Titan science means
exactly well that's it for today's video
guys let me know what you think about
Levi mucus of being the byproducts of
Titan science and any questions you have
about the comments section below
thanks a lot for watching and thank you
for all of your support guys if you
enjoyed this video be sure to go
ackerman mode on that like button and
subscribe for more
attack on Titan videos until next time
SIA space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]